results for edgbaston consistency
Birmingham 472 may 2015 I hereby declare
that the total number of votes given for
each candidate is as follows drug Lee
James Liberal Democrats 1184 Evans dr.
Luke the Conservative Party candidate
fifteen thousand eight hundred and
twelve rye henna independent 91
short-grain George UK Independence Party
4000 154 Simpson filled the Green Party
1003 and 71 Stuart khislar Labour Party
18,000 518 the condo Gabriel Christian
party
proclaiming fishes lordship one in 63
the number of rejected ballot paper was
156 total 40 1449 this represents a
majority of two thousand seven and six
forgiveness Stuart who is duly elected
to serve as a member of Birmingham
edgbaston constituency turnout 63 point
not a 63 point nineteen percent I would
light white gives us to you to come
forward and say a few words I'd like to
thank everyone involved in the count
tonight for the smooth running including
the police and the mayor for your very
gracious way of declaring the results
but above all I want to thank the voters
of each person who have again shown
their confidence not just in me but
actually in the team that has been
working in education across the four
wards for a year after year and it is
because of that cross community working
that we've won again I want to thank
Caroline badly the brains behind the
whole operations are very special time
here and I also want to thank the voters
for continuing the most extraordinary
tradition of women MPs in each person
it's been 62 years so far and it looks
as if this is set to go on but on a
serious point the next year's are going
to be hard for this city it's not going
to get any easier and we are not going
to get through these hard times for a
city that is the youngest in Europe that
has to provide jobs that has to provide
for the economy if we actually pull
together if you go and finding things
which bring us together rather than
looking for things which divide us and I
think edge Preston has shown the way
forward and the rest of our labor
colleagues across the city this true
labor city will continue that thank you
very much indeed